this video is made possible by Vince
arrow watches luxury handcrafted watches
fair prices you can check them out
through the link below which historical
figure springs to mind when you hear the
words the last king of the French we're
guessing it's probably louis xvi the
long head for who lost his head in the
French Revolution but what if we told
you that the story of france's Kings
didn't ends with the guillotine slicing
through Louie's neck in 1793 what if we
told you that France didn't say goodbye
to its last King until over 50 years
later well it's time you met that king
Louis Philippe was a man whose life
turned on revolution born into an
aristocratic family he survived the
first French Revolution that killed his
father only to become king in yet
another revolution that toppled his
father's cousin as a figurehead of the
July monarchy he survived rebellions and
Napoleonic Coos before losing everything
and the streets of Paris once more rose
up this time against him a lifelong
liberal who became a dictator King an
exile who grew up to rule the nation
that exiled him this is the complex
fascinating life story of Louis Philippe
the last king of the French
[Music]
in the early hours of October the sick
for 1789 fate handed the teenage
louis-philippe a front-row seat to
history the previous evening a huge mob
of women had gathered in Paris and set
off for Versailles the opulent palace of
King Louis the 16th the Marie Antoinette
it was the early days of the French
Revolution not three months before the
Bastille had fallen and now here Louis
Philippe was leaning out of a window on
a cool October night as the women of
Paris forcibly dragged the king and his
family back to the capital watching the
procession of women passing below Louis
Philippe had good reason to be scared he
was the eldest son of the Duke de Leon
the captured King was his first cousin
once removed but 16 year-old Louie
Philippe he wasn't scared
he was already planning to ride this
wave of revolution to greatness born on
October the 6th 1773 Louis Philippe had
what you might describe as an unusual
upbringing his father the Duke Thalia
was obsessed with social experimentation
while other raw children were learning
the basics of ruling Louis Philippe and
his siblings were contemplating
strenuous physical tasks while reciting
jean-jacques rousseau this meant a
childhood that left the boy in excellent
physical and mental shape and the father
with a reputation as a very unwell role
this reputation it turned out to be
useful when the French Revolution hit
while other aristocrats fled into exile
the Duke was elected to the
revolutionary National Assembly changing
his name to Philippe égalité e so when
teenager Louis Philippe witnessed the
1789 women's March from cold-open
he didn't panic instead he joined the
Jacobin Club that's the same Jacobin
Club Ross Pierre came from and he also
enrolled in the French army as France
went to war with Austria in 1792 Louis
Philippe found himself soaring up the
ranks eventually becoming attached to
the staff of general du Maurier at this
stage it might have seemed like the
revolution was a godsend for the only
old family in January of 1793 the Duke
or Philippe legality or whatever you
want to call him he voted alongside the
National Assembly to execute his cousin
near the sixteenth but this was just the
family's high points like a
rollercoaster cart approaching the top
of a peak the only way for the only on
clan now was down in april of 1793 Louie
Philippe discovered general du Marais
was plotting a coup while he didn't join
the plots he also didn't reporters which
became pretty awkward when the coup was
uncovered as general du Marais and his
fellow plotters fled to Austria Louie
Philippe was forced to flee alongside
them suddenly the only own name was
synonymous with counter-revolution back
in Paris the Committee of Public Safety
arrested the entire family that November
Philippe égalité II was guillotines
Louis Philippe was hiding in Switzerland
when he got the news that his father was
dead and that he now was the Duke of
Ollie off for the rest of his life he
would blame himself for his father's
death the next few years were a
turbulent time in Europe while the way
Philippe travelled the consonance under
an assumed name in France the
thermidorian reaction ended the reign of
terror and sent Robespierre to the
guillotine in the place of the
revolutionary governments the directory
rose up it was their agents who finally
tracked Louis Philippe to Denmark in
the directory wasn't as vicious as
robbers Pierre's goon-squad however they
did not want an ally or running around
Europe especially now exiled orally
honest were plotting to put the new Duke
on the French throne so they decided to
make me Philippe an offer he couldn't
refuse get out of Europe and we won't
guillotine the rest of your family and
that was how the future French King
Louie Philippe he wound up going to
America
despite the directory's fears Louie
Philippe he wasn't much of a threat when
Olly honest started plotting to
overthrow the directory and make him
King the new Duke was super clear that
he wanted nothing to do with this
harebrained scheme that may be why in
1800 he was finally able to make peace
with the Comte d'Artois the Comte was
the younger brother of Louis the
sixteenth hit fled into exile with his
older brother Louis the 18th right after
the Revolution exploded and he was now
living in England when Louis Philippe
joins the cops after a couple of years
in America the comps had every reason to
hate the only own name remember the
lastik had voted for his brother's
execution the comps living brother Louie
the 18th was even convinced that the
entire revolution had been an ally
honest plot but this was 1800 the
directory had now fallen with the
situation in France in flux that Comte
was determines that the royal family
rebuild their bridges
so despite Louie the 18th being all like
well do know the Comte invited leery
Philippe back into the fold
not that this reconciliation had much
real-world effect by the time the family
made up Napoleon Bonaparte was firmly in
control of France and no one was
clamoring for a royal return that was
pretty much it for the next decade while
Napoleon did his thing conquering
everything in sight maybe Philippe
potted around London doing whatever it
is that Kings do in exile before we
moved to Sicily to marry Marie
Antoinette's niece and really his story
it kind of could have ended there were
it not for 1812 1812 is the year that
Napoleon made the classic dictator
mistake of invading Russia as his army
and Empire disintegrated around him it
began to look like Napoleon wouldn't be
needing France for very much longer all
of this it raised a potent question who
would as the Allies marched into Paris
in April of 1814 it wasn't clear who
would get the restored French throne
while Louie the 18th was the obvious
choice there was a powerful ally honest
movement in parts of French society that
wanted Duke to be king it didn't help
that Louie Philippe kept quiet right
until the last second when he finally
declared for louis xviii something that
the Duke was cajoled into this by
more likely though the Allies had a bit
of a quiet word with him something like
dude we do not need you screwing up a
post Napoleon plans by starting a civil
war yo anyway louis philippe's late
support for louis xviii definitely was
not wholehearted during the hundred days
when the Polian escaped Elba and
returned to France Louis Philippe lurked
around Paris looking for all the world
like someone waiting to snatch the
throne when Napoleon inevitably fell
again after Waterloo when Louie the 18th
was restored for the second time Louis
Philippe began lavishing gifts and
patronage upon liberals looking for all
the world like someone trying to fashion
himself as an attractive alternative
King but the clearest indication we have
about the Dukes ambitions came in
September of 1820 earlier that year the
Comte Artois surviving son had been
assassinated with his death Louis
Philippe had become third in line to the
throne but then it turns out that the
dead man had impregnated his wife before
dying seven months later she gave birth
to that child on re and just like that
Louis Philippe was out of the running
for King the news of the miracle baby
gave Louie Philippe a breakdown he
reportedly collapsed when the news
reached him wailing that only or would
now never amount to anything
it was a touch melodramatic and it was
also untrue nobody at that time had any
way of knowing it but Louie Philippe was
just one good revolution away from
becoming King on September the 16th 1824
louis xviii passed away in his place the
Comte d'Artois
assumes the French throne under the name
Charles the tenth but this time Louie
Philippe it more or less given up on
being King becoming instead a big play
on the business scene and the Friends of
the bourgeois liberals in the
government's opposition thus the duke
was perfectly placed to see just how
quickly france soured on charles the
tenth back when louis xviii ER descended
in 1814 a bunch of people in france had
basically been like whoa timeout right
now we don't want another corrupt Louie
learning over us with absolute power
that is not cool
right so maybe the eighteenth had signed
something called the Charter of 1814
Semmy Constitution the basic
said the king shalt not act like a
gigantic dickhead although he had
thought the Charter an outrage he stood
by it out of necessity realizing that
times have changed but Charles didn't
get the message
almost the first thing he did after
being coronated was to figuratively bend
over and used the Charter to wipe his
bottom under Charles's ministry freedom
of speech it was axed capital punishment
for religious offences was revived and
the franchise was restricted until not
even the wealthy bourgeois could vote by
1830 Charles was so close to being a
dictator that his advisors actually
advised that he launched a royal coup so
he did on Sunday July the 25th 1830
Charles published something known as the
four ordinances this outlawed his
opposition and also freedom of the press
his government's thought it was a
masterstroke the people of Paris they
thought differently that Monday the
French capital trembled with unrest
there were protests anti-monarchy chants
the Smashing of property it might have
died down of its own accord had Charles
not sent in the army to shoot some of
the protesters as an example it was as
effective a suicide as if Charles had
tied a rock to his neck and dived
headfirst into the sin the next day July
the 27th 1830 Paris it went up in flames
across the capital rioters built
barricades and armed themselves when the
soldiers came storming in firefights
erupted there was carnage it was blood
in the streets out maneuvered by the
angry Parisians the army simply had to
abandon the city as they left the last
thing Charles's soldiers saw was the
white flag of the monarchy being torn
down and the revolutionary tricky law
hoisted in the air and with that the
July revolution had begun so where you
might ask well was Louie Philippe
well not anywhere really the future King
was holed up at his a stage trying his
absolute best not to look like someone
waiting around who snatched the throne
after Charles was guillotines it was his
liberal opposition friends in Paris who
were doing all of the work as Paris fell
to the rioters the upper bourgeois
businessman and opposition leaders as
Louis Philippe surrounded himself with
got together and decided that they
needed to do something the July
revolution had caught them all by
surprise they were glad the street
fighters of Paris seemed to want to
radical Charles
gone but were equally terrified the next
logical step would be a Robespierre
revival group wheeling out the
guillotine
so they hatched a plan to make sure that
this time the Duke de Leon succeeded in
his dreams of becoming King with most of
the newspapers on their side they
printed out posters declaring Paris was
revolting and that the Duke de olio was
the last friend of the people
then they dispatched an emissary to
Louis Philippe's estate who told him to
get his ass to Paris and grab the
opportunity that they just handed him
Louie Philippe arrived in Paris just
before midnight on Friday July the 30th
1830 that same evening Charles the tenth
fled his palace ahead of a lynch mob
just like that the King was gone and the
French throne was suddenly vacant now
all Louis Philippe needed to do was
convince the rioters to let him take it
but before he get into all of that and
believe me it's all worth the wait I do
want to tell you about our fantastic
sponsor Vince aro watches I'm wearing a
Vince arrow right now this one is a
Vince arrow chronograph as well as
keeping perfect time it's also got a
timer see these three back dials there
they don't just look great but they also
serve a function now I picked out a
watch with a blue and silver combination
as you can see but there are loads of
options on their website you'll be sure
to find something that suits your style
and your wrist size I've got a small
little wrists so they've got smaller
models one of them fit me perfectly with
summer coming up I'd also recommend you
check out their new Kairos mesh series
they've got breathable straps so there's
no sweating into it and getting all
uncomfortable and these watches can also
be dressed up or dressed down and fit
with lots of different styles also all
the watch bands on Vince arrow watches
are interchangeable so you can easily
get a new look for your one watch
you can also buy those watch strap
separately when Sarah watches believe
that luxury isn't about price or
specification it's about detail and
craftsmanship and Vince era watches
they've got a lot of that unlike many
other watches on the market Vince area
is not about minimalist style it's more
about the classic good look of a wash
which something I love further my
selling direct to the consumer Vince
Eric and deliver a great watch at a much
better price than you might be expecting
to see the full range go to in Sarah
watch it's calm /bo graphics and use the
code bio graphics on checkout for a
special discount
thanks to Vince area watches for
sponsoring
let's crack on shall we
[Music]
have you had one of those morning's
where you wake up remember what you did
last night and then just immediately
curl up into a ball and start screaming
well I was a newbie Phillipe this
morning on July the 31st 1830 when he
realized it just toppled his cousin
once-removed and willingly rode into the
middle of revolutionary Paris Louis
Philippe had a total meltdown he
actually begged all those liberals oohed
dragged in there not to make him King
which must have seemed well both sorts
of ironic but there was no way he could
back out now the simple truth was that
if someone didn't take this
revolutionary bull by the horns the July
revolution it wasn't gonna stop with
Charles and well everyone present had
all-too-real memories of the swish and
funk sound of the guillotine in the end
Lewis leap he agreed to clear up the
mess draping himself in the trickle or
he rode out into the raging streets of
Paris now this was dangerous no one in
Paris had gone into this revolt because
they desperately wanted to replace one
doughy King with another royal lard-ass
by riding out like that me Philippe was
putting himself at real risk of someone
screaming that guy is a Duke cut off his
head the reason that this didn't happen
is largely thanks to the Marquis de
Lafayette a legendary French hero who'd
played a significant role in both the
American and original French Revolutions
the Marquis was respected by everyone
even Parisian street fighters when he
met Louis Philippe outside the Hotel de
Ville and enthusiastically embraced him
it sent a clear signal to Paris the
Revolution was over not that Charles the
tenth that realized it though still
alive with his head attached to his body
the King was desperately scheming to get
his family back onto the throne the plan
II Hassan was almost ingenious the
people wanted a new king well he'd give
them one hit abdicate for his grandson
the miracle baby we mentioned earlier
there was a cunning move that could have
saved bourbon line unfortunately for
Charles though the idea came too late
as Charles was abdicating Paris was
watching Louis Philippe and the Marquis
de Lafayette waving the trickle offer
from a balcony signaling the dawn of a
new era
any thoughts the people of Paris had of
allowing another born to take the throne
it died that very day or is the ninth
Louie Philippe was crowned it
agreed before hands that he would take
the title of king of the French implying
a public servants you looked after his
people rather than the traditional title
of King of France which implied a grumpy
landlord angry with all of these
peasants stinking up the place it was
the moment Louie Philippe had been
waiting for his entire life 41 years ago
the new king of the French had leaned
out of a window and watched as Paris as
women marched King Louie the sixteenth
back from Versailles now here he was
wearing the crown his long dead relative
had lost to the guillotine he wasn't
just the survivor of two French
Revolutions he was the beneficiary as
Charles the tenth fled into exile the
establishment of Louie Philippe's July
monarchy looks a whole lot more like a
new chapter in French roll history one
that would establish a new and glorious
dynasty in a way this was right it
really was a new chapter for France's
monarchy but it was also its last
[Music]
the July monarchy was popular for maybe
about 23 minutes before reality hit the
problem was Louie Philippe had been put
on the throne by a bunch of bourgeois
liberals but the people who'd done all
the fighting and dying during that July
revolution they were workers and they
wanted progress to show for all that
bloodshed Louis Philippe failed to
deliver on this spectacularly now sure
he wasn't anywhere near as autocratic as
Charles more people could vote freedom
of the press was guaranteed and the
government had a healthy opposition but
if he was some unemployed prison street
fighter less autocratic than the last
guy wasn't exactly what you'd been
fighting for in the first few years of
his existence the July monarchy had to
face down all manner of threats there
was a Bonaparte his plot to topple Louie
Philippe and put one of Napoleon's
relatives on the throne there was also a
legitimate uprising to topple Louis
Philippe and replace him with Charles's
grandson there was also the infamous
June rebellion of 1832 the one Linzer
habla is based upon this prison uprising
left 800 people dead ironically though
all these attempted revolts actually
showed up Louis Philippe's support faced
with the prospect of a not great monarch
or the workers wheeling out the
guillotine the middle classes always
chose the monarchy but there was one man
who swore in the July monarchy not a
bulwark against terror but a golden
opportunity yep it's time to welcome
into this story
our old friend Napoleon the third if
you're no doubt recall if you saw our
previous video about him the pony on
third was the exiled nephew of the
original Napoleon now living under the
insane delusion that he should be
Emperor of France he was also a gigantic
pain in louis philippe's derriere in
1836 when Louie Philippe was desperately
trying to shore up support Napoleon the
third launched a tragically inept coup
in Strasbourg that succeeded only in
embarrassing everyone when Louie
Philippe tried to return the pony in the
first sashes to France in 1840 Napoleon
the third was there again soaking up the
limelight by launching yet another coup
so incompetent that even anti Bonaparte
us felt sorry for him unable to deal
with the bad publicity executing a
living link to Napoleon the first would
bring Louie Philippe simply had the one
of the Emperor locked up but he could
afford to be lenient on crazy old
Napoleon the third in 1840 by that point
the July monarchy it was
no longer really unpopular this was more
of an accidents than any grand plan on
louis philippe's part between 1840 and
1846 France had experienced an economic
boom that hoisted up living standards
and kept the middle classes happy but
even during these halcyon days the
warning signs they were there for the
monarchies future Louis Philippe's most
important Minister was a guy called
Francois
Keizo the conservative iron fist in the
Kings soft liberal glove as the economy
boomed Gazoo used precisely none of that
money to support the lower classes those
men and women who'd mans the barricades
during the July revolution mom they got
squat it wasn't just money they didn't
get although one of the July monarchy is
Resort air throwies to enlarge the
franchise that had been so restricted
under Charles voting was still only
something that the 1% could do the rest
of the country was starting to wonder
why their voices were not being heard
and that's where things were as 1846
rolled into view the July monarchy who
was popular ish just so long as the good
times kept on rolling and no massive
shock upset the precarious foundation of
sans that dewy Philippe had built his
royal house on but this is Louie
Philippe were talking about the king
whose life turned on revolutions little
did the king of the French know but he
was fast approaching his final one
[Music]
On January the 29th 1848 Alexei de
tocqueville got to his feet in the
French Chamber of Deputies and made a
prophetic speech I'm told there is no
danger because there are no riots I am
told that because there is no visible
disorder on the surface of society there
is no revolution at hands gentlemen
permit me to say that I believe you are
deceived this is my profound conviction
I believe that we are at this moment
sleeping on a volcano it was two years
on from where we last left Louie
Philippe hoping the good times would
never stop rolling in fact they'd not
stopped rolling the entire cart had
fallen to pieces 1846 had seen a major
recession hit France throwing millions
out of work at the same time a great
famine had swept Europe making life so
painful that the decade became known as
the hungry 40s
this was the volcano that Tocqueville
was talking about a France boiling with
invisible rage hidden by a restrictive
franchise that locked most people out of
power only the discontent it wasn't
entirely invisible the previous year
opposition deputies had begun organizing
banquets across France in order to air
their grievances under the July monarchy
protest was illegal so private bank
words that just happened to feature
political speeches were a way around
this law tens of thousands attended
among them Friedrich Engels of the
Communist Manifesto Fame by January 1848
the banquet campaign has mostly fizzled
out the organizers decided to put
together one last grand one in Paris to
cap off the year's work only this
banquet
it didn't go ahead fed up with even this
limited freedom of speech the gayssot
government banned it at the last second
this was a big deal even under the July
monarchy people they had a right to
assemble after some debate the
organizers decided to reschedule for
February the 22nd they would hold a
symbolic banquet just to prove that they
still had rights and then disperse
without making any political speeches
that was how on February 22nd 1848 Paris
found itself hosting thousands upon
thousands of super politicized people
angry and primed to believe that
canceling the day's banquet
would signal the complete stripping of
their rights if you've watched our other
nineteenth-century videos you may have
heard us joke before about how a ban on
banquets somehow sparked a revolution in
France in 1848 well this is how faced
with all these hostile people right in
the heart of Paris he's--oh canceled the
banquet anyway these hostile people then
did what Bhangra pas star people tend to
do within hours of the cancellation
barricades were springing up across the
city workers they were arming themselves
by the morning of February 23rd Paris
was a gigantic tinderbox the city was
paralyzed by crowds demanding Jesus head
terrified by what it unleashed his Oh
resigned but then some random soldier
decided to throw a match runs the highly
combustible situation by opening fire on
the crowds that had gathered to hear
Jesus resignation when the smoke cleared
52 Parisians were dead this Massacre
when it caused the volcano to blow its
top by dawn of February the 24th the
French capital it was out of control the
army was mutinying in the National Guard
were joining the revolutionaries today
some historians think that if Louis
Philippe had ordered loyal regiments of
the army to attack the city that July
monarchy could have survived but here's
the thing about nuit Philippe at heart
he wanted to be loved for all of his
faults this was a man who when King had
wandered the streets of Paris in a
businessman suit shaking hands with his
subjects he was ambitious yes but he
also genuinely believed that he was
popular to cast that last illusion aside
by attacking Paris it was just simply a
step too far that date February the 24th
1848 Louis Philippe abdicated the French
crown at the last moment he tried to
take a leave from Charles the tenths
played oaken's make his grandson king
but what hadn't worked for Charles did
not work for Louis Philippe either On
February 26 1848 with France in revolt
the French monarchy was abolished for
good there would be no more Kings no
more queens the last chapter of the
monarchy attended not in glory but with
Louis Philippe fleeing into exile
however that was a postscript across
Europe the July monarchies collapse it
triggered a wave of revolutions in
Austria Hungary Italy and Prussia old
certainties they were now swept away and
news stories were written
back in France the end of Louie
Philippe's story it wound up being the
start of another man's that's right
it's Santha Napoleon the third to step
back into the spotlight within months of
Louis Philippe's fall the bumbling coup
plotter was riding this latest wave of
revolution just as Louis Philippe had
with the July revolution on December the
10th Napoleon the third became the first
ever president of France not four years
later he declared himself Emperor for
life as Napoleon the third was snatching
Louis Philippe's crown now with extra
Imperial trimming the one-time Duke was
settling into a short unhappy retirement
in England and we mean short on August
the 26th 1850 not three years after his
final revolution Louie Philippe passed
away he was 76
so was Louie Philippe a tyrant a schemer
or was he just unlucky maybe more likely
he was just an anachronism a man who
decided that he'd one day be king and
fulfilled their dream just as France was
deciding that it no longer needed a
monarchy today the last king of the
French is little more than a footnote in
history but we shouldn't let that
distract us from the miracle that was
Louis Philippe's turbulent life he was a
man who survived three separate French
Revolutions three times he found himself
at the epicenter of European history in
the end his entire life was perhaps no
difference from that of the
sixteen-year-old boy that it once been
the boy who leaned out of his window I
love the women's march on Versailles
determined to witness history so I
really hope you found that video
interesting if you did please do give us
a thumbs up below and don't forget to
subscribe we've got brand new videos
just like this several times a week also
please do check a lot great sponsor
Vince arrow watches you will find them
below and as always thank you for
watching
[Music]